around the world the trend towards a
cashless Society is accelerating but
what will that digital future look like
and how will it vary across the globe
the economists correspondents share
their insights on the major digital
payment systems in three key markets
[Music]
there have been sort of a few winners
from this trend
um which sort of really accelerated uh
during covid-19 during the pandemic when
people were sort of having to shop for
everything from home in particular in
places like the US people have been
using those cards more and more as
payments have shifted more digitally the
reason that network is so
um sort of entrenched and so resilient
is because it has an extremely sort of
clever underlying model which is that
the card issuers Visa and MasterCard
charge enormous fees to the merchants uh
the sort of Shoppers so you know your
coffee shop or or even sort of Amazon
and Walmart
and those Merchants feel like they sort
of have to pay those fees they have to
accept these cards because they are so
ubiquitous uh most of that fee is sort
of routed uh to the the issuing bank so
JPMorgan Chase or Citibank or whoever
sort of issued the credit card that
you're using uh but they use that fee to
then pay the consumers who use those
cards sort of really enormous rewards so
this is the sort of air miles or hotel
points or cashback that Americans have
become sort of so accustomed to
receiving uh the cards also come with
sort of huge amounts of sort of consumer
protection uh so you know if something
isn't delivered as uh described or sort
of an airline cancels your ticket you
have recourse through these credit card
companies and they can afford sort of
all of those luxuries because the fees
are so high and so it is very difficult
to see sort of what could
um could disrupt that model because
consumers love to use these cards and uh
and Merchants feel like they have to
accept them
what India is doing is really a
fundamentally different model than you
know what we have in the west or really
even what uh you know China has with
digital payments um so it's called a
unified payment interface or UPI uh it's
now the largest digital payment Network
in the country a processed a trillion
dollars in transactions last year that's
about a third of India's GDP uh and the
way it works the government has set up
uh you know a non-profit that's
partially owned by the central bank and
it basically sits in the middle of every
uh mobile transaction in the country
um so there are a lot of banks a lot of
fintech wallets in India just like other
countries but what they've done is
they've made them all uh talk to each
other uh what's called interoperability
uh where the UPI system sits in the
middle of each one and they have a
common set of standards and apis that a
lot allows for payments between uh my
bank account and your bank account
directly facilitated by a fintech app in
the UPI system uh and so it's different
than uh you know the West because
there's no need for a credit card
Network and so you know people who only
have a mobile phone and may not have a
credit history and might not be able to
get into the financial system otherwise
are now able to do digital payments
um I think that's like a pretty big
change for a country that was previously
mostly uh using cash one of the things
that's so fascinating is how a shift
towards these type of payments can
unlock a whole range of other changes
within the financial system as people
have uh more data generated about their
transactions so it changes their credit
worthiness which in turn might change
their ability to get insurance or loans
how is that playing out in India loan
provision has basically taken off uh you
know as a result of the data produced by
UPI they have a system where you can
basically export your data let's say
you're using one payment app or One Bank
you can export your data it's called the
account aggregator system and then you
can import it into another uh you know
Financial Services environment so
basically allows you to kind of own your
own data and then get you know financial
services from anyone and I think that
that like kind of linkage between
payments and other Financial Services is
what's really taking off around the
world
[Music]
of the newest model I think it's fair to
say or one of the newest models in India
you have this 60 year old model in
America and Europe with the the bank
card system and then in China you have
something different right which is it
which is neither uh you have a statistic
in your report origin about how Ali pain
WeChat control about 90 percent of
digital payments in China and I remember
the last time I was in China this is
pre-pandemic but trying to pay for
something with my credit card and it was
even at a western chain I think it was a
Starbucks and they had to go to the back
and get out a credit card machine and
plug it in because everyone else was
paying with their phones and so tell us
for people who might not be familiar
what that payment system looks like and
what its longevity is you think in China
or how it might be used elsewhere so
it's not it's not an open system uh like
UPI is but it's also not like a card
network uh how the US Works rather it's
you know a fintech app um or two as you
mentioned alipay and WeChat pay and
their clothes networks that means uh you
know you can typically only pay from one
alipay account to another alipay account
or from one WeChat pay account to
another WeChat pay account and the
reason why the the system kind of took
off the way it did is because in 2011 um
you know alipay at Financial they
basically uh you know at the time was
Alibaba they basically launched uh a QR
Code system where you could basically
scan a QR code at a merchant shop and
then you could pay directly and that was
really groundbreaking because previously
you needed expensive card readers as you
mentioned uh which you know a lot of
businesses in an Emerging Market you
know don't really want to spend money on
which is why they would prefer cash but
QR codes are super cheap you just need
to you know slap a sticker on your
storefront and then you can start
accepting digital payments and by then
smartphones were getting you know
becoming more ubiquitous
so that's kind of what allowed alipay to
really take off and then WeChat pay was
able to basically copy it and grow
because you know WeChat was used for
messaging right it's kind of like you
know as ubiquitous as like a Facebook is
in the west uh and so you know everyone
was already onboarded on their platform
so it was very easy for them to kind of
already have the network effects built
in uh and then simply add the payment
business on top of that and so just to
give you a context some context on the
numbers here you mentioned the 90
percent of uh statistics right 90 of
digital payments were happening on these
two platforms it's also a hugely
valuable business because the other
services they put around uh the payment
so you know all you pay got Financial
got really into lending right
um you know right before uh covid uh you
know something around 20 of all
short-term Consumer Credit was
originated by amp Financial which is you
know insane when you think about uh you
know how much money is going uh into
lending in these countries as opposed to
IPO for you know 300 billion dollars but
of course that was blocked by the
government
um and in fact you know the the kind of
presence of this type of dominant
payment provider that controls so much
of the financial system was a bit scary
to the to the Chinese government which
is why they ended up doing what they did
and that was actually you know uh uh one
of the motivations for why UPI was
designed the way it was
um is so the system didn't create such
huge uh individual player that
controlled so much of Finance
this video is part of a longer
discussion between the economist
journalists if you're a subscriber you
can watch the whole thing please click
this link see you next time
foreign
[Applause]